is now 6 42 here on a tuesday morning
ces
as you know is underway but it is not in
las vegas this year it's virtual because
of the pandemic
but that doesn't mean we can't talk
about gadgets look who's with us once
again it's our old buddy dr frank the
tech expert dr frank good to see you
again sir hopefully you're doing well
john i'm doing great good to see you as
well certainly miss you guys but
hopefully we'll get there next year
all right so let's get right into things
here you're a judge at the ces
innovation awards this year
i look at some of the products on that
desk there are those some of those cool
gadgets
oh absolutely yeah the first one
actually the company is based in las
vegas
and it's very interesting it's called
mirage vision and what's happening with
the pandemic you know
we all know it's changed lives but
people are investing in their homes
they're actually remodeling bathrooms
and kitchens and also they're looking at
the outdoors because of the safety of
covid
and they're installing theaters and
they're installing tvs
and what mirage vision has done is
they've come up when they basically have
outdoor televisions
that withstand rain snow dust it really
doesn't matter
perfect for the patio the deck backyard
pool etc
and what's interesting and you can
probably see in the video they're
actually squirting the tv with
water with a hose so that's how
waterproof they are and by the way these
are the same tvs
that you'll see at luxury hotels in las
vegas like the mgm
caesars and the upcoming resort world
and they have a partnership with samsung
which allows weatherization which means
that it assures you that that tv is
going to last outdoors
regardless both 4k and 8k technology
but what i like it's 10 times brighter
than your normal tv at home
they start under a thousand bucks and
they go in sizes from 12 inches to
200. wow 200 that i feel like that's 200
inches yep it's almost
32 inches i'm sorry 32 inches to 200
it's almost
unnecessary uh what else do you got
there it looks like uh there's something
funny
electric charging yeah vehicle you know
electric vehicles are really catching on
john
the the problem is people have battery
anxiety what is that
that means you're driving in your car
and you're thinking oh my goodness i
hope the battery lasts
because if it doesn't i'm going to have
to charge it so what a cell has come up
with
is a portable electric vehicle charger
this thing is amazing
the beauty of the product is that you
can throw this in the trunk which is
great
and you can charge your vehicle anywhere
so you go to visit a friend
you plug into the receptacle you take
the sl portable electric vehicle charger
and it charges the battery they have
both level one and level two products
so therefore whether you've got a tesla
gm ford it doesn't matter
comes with a 24.6 foot cable which is
great
and the other thing i like about it nice
carrying case two-year limited warranty
and sells for about 469 people always
want to know where do you get this stuff
available at you know at slw.com their
website
costco has it and so does amazon very
interesting yeah you're right a lot of a
lot of folks are driving those electric
cars these days
another thing that a lot of folks have
we have all this data now we've got
pictures
music gaming we need to store our data
somewhere
if we don't maybe feel comfortable with
the cloud talk about a device that you
guys are working on there
now you make a terrific point john and
that's exactly what the owc
envoy does this is basically an advanced
storage
product and they basically their their
whole company is about advanced storage
technology
but what i love about what you said is
you don't have to have the cloud you buy
this you own it
you retain all that data information
videos photos etc
but it's one of the fastest and most
reliable drives that i've tested
it's perfect for audio video photography
graphics gaming
data storage etc and the interesting
thing about it
it's bus powered the other thing that
this product does which i like
is it is compatible with macs pcs ipads
etc and it goes way back
that if you have a product that's 10
years old or older it's going to work
the other thing that's interesting
only a few con
the nug they'll be to see this drum
proof and waterproof rated and passive
drop house which is very
good a military draw this comes in
anywhere from a 240 gig to a 2 terabyte
model
and they start at 169. it's incredible
how fast those solid state drives are
i've used one of those myself from my
computer at home it's incredible how
quick those things are
uh let's finally just talk quickly about
water leaks they can
ruin your lawns they can have a big
effect on you uh what are some
some devices to try and help us with
that yes this is
a company called peril protect which is
really cool one thing you need to know
is that 7
000 homes every day have water damage
and are affected by broken pipes frozen
pipes etc
and these repairs can actually average
ten thousand dollars and higher
so what does paraprotect do is you
basically take the sensors and you place
the sensors near the toilet
near the bathtub area washer dryer
dishwasher etc and what it does it'll
detect water it then notifies you
depending upon the program that you have
with periprotect they start at about
23.99
they can actually dispatch someone to
your your home
well other way ideal for anybody
and they're concerned and check with
your insurance agent because many times
when you install something like this
what's important is that the premiums go
down
yeah and dr frank those leaks can lead
to mold and among other things dr frank
we got to go
good to see you again take care of
yourself we hope to see you in person as
soon as possible
good to see you thank you john all right
at 6